sur public sénat bonjour à tous merci de
nous rejoindre en direct sur public
sénat pour la séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
c'est en ce qui va démarrer dans
l'hémicycle du sénat dans une quinzaine
de minutes avec parmi les thèmes abordés
cet après-midi la gouvernance économique
européenne
la conférence sociale souhaitait pas le
gouvernement l'enseignement en anglais à
l'université alors que l'amendement a
été adopté par l'assemblée nationale
tout à l'heure en fin de matinée
également une question sur le crédit
d'impôt pour la compétitivité et
l'emploi ou encore sur la situation en
syrie j'ai donc des thèmes très divers
abordés par les sénateurs lors des
questions d'actualité cet après midi
avant de suivre en direct cette séance
nous recevons alain vidalies sts
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement bonjour bonjour merci d'être
avec nous pour faire un petit peu le
point sur l'actualité cet après midi
tout d'abord cette information qui vient
de nous parvenir frigide barjot qui se
dit pas tout à fait certaine d'aller
manifester dimanche contre le texte
mariage pour tous qui a donc été
promulguée parce qu'elle se dit menacé
et donc sa sécurité ne serait pas
assurée lors de la manifestation
dimanche
écoutez je pense que c'est révélateur
d'un climat parmi les parmi les
organisateurs je sais que cette affaire
est aujourd'hui derrière nous tu m'as
parmi les organisateurs c'est pas elle
qui serait menacée par d'autres
groupuscules non mais ça je vends je
n'en sais rien mais peut-être que vous
vous le savez moi je ne sais pas je pas
pensé d'appréciation naturellement mais
je pense qu'il y avait des vraies
interrogations on le voit bien et qui
sont nourris par le fait que des groupes
d'extrême droite ont été très présents
dans les précédentes manifestations
qu'ils le seront encore et que
naturellement ceux qui participent
peuvent s'interroger sur les conditions
du déroulement de cette manifestation
que pensez vous de la présence
lui notamment de députés ump ou de
sénateur ump dans cette manifestation
alors que la loi a été promulguée
vous savez c'est d'abord usé droit de
manifester est un droit fondamental
les personnes valeur contester ce qui
serait intéressant c'est connaît une
seule réponse ah qu'est ce que vous
ferez parce qu'au fond y compris pour
les gens qui manifestent
il n'y a qu'une seule issue c'est qu'un
jour peut-être il y ait une autre
majorité mais savoir ce que fera cette
majorité on voit bien aujourd'hui qui a
autant d'élus que de discours et dans
tous les cas un discours qui est tout à
fait discret dans à droite le président
de la république était en allemagne ce
matin life cycle et où les loups et les
réformes du marché du travail mené par
gerhard schröder l'ancien chancelier
pardon c'est à dire une plus grande
flexibilité du marché du travail ce qui
n'a pas toujours fait l'unanimité au
sein de la gauche européenne c'est ce
que ça veut dire qu'en france on
progresse vraiment vers plus de social
démocratie
je crois qu'il faut être très clair j'ai
vu cette dépêche le plaisir la
république et ce matin alexis coup on
fête le 150e anniversaire d'un grand
parti qu'est le spd allemand il fait un
historique vivacité sur 150 ans tous les
responsables allemands socialistes qui
ont exercé le pouvoir et il parle
évidemment du dernier ces de gerhard
schröder et je vois une dépêche qui dit
qu'il a particulièrement vanté une
phrase une phrase sur l'ensemble du
discours que j'ai devant moi et donc je
pense qu'il faut pas se lancer dans un
buzz qui le méritent pas car il faut
mettre ce phrase dans ce contexte et
surtout lire la suite la suite de
président de la république et c'était
normal il n'allait pas dire critiquer
quoi que ce soit il et en allemagne et
il parle de nos amis allemands de la
politique qu'ils ont menées et il ajoute
donc je le lis pas ce que vous pourrez
les choses soient claires je réponds que
tout n'est pas transposable nos pays
sont différents nos histoires ne sont
pas interchangeables c'est plaisant la
république qui parle
nos cultures politiques syndicales sont
singulières je garde la
social-démocratie le sens du dialogue la
recherche du compromis et la synthèse
permanente entre la performance
économique et la justice sociale
donc si on veut avoir une véritable
image de ce qu'il a dit dans quel
contexte il faut prendre l'ensemble et
il n'y a rien à retrancher mais dans la
même dépêche
république salue aussi des réformes très
courageuse qui ont été faits par la
chancellerie moder et qu'il faudra sans
doute y venir aussi en france non non ça
c'est un commentaire que vous faites et
je ne retiens pas et je dis très
clairement qu'il n'y a pas dans cette du
compte rendu historique des propositions
qui pourraient permettre à quiconque de
dire qu'il ya eu de la part du président
de la république la volonté de
transposer en france
la nati les réformes qui ont été faites
par gerhard schröder pour que les choses
soient claires il a salué ce qui a été
fait en allemagne en soulignant la
différence de culture entre nos deux
pays
d'accord ça veut dire que vous vous ne
souhaitez pas cette transposition en
france et en allemagne
non mais pas moi le président de la
république n'a pas dit ça ce matin il a
remercié ce qui a été fait partout
l'ensemble des responsables allemands
et il n'a jamais proposé la
transposition en france de ces
propositions
le sénat examine cette semaine le texte
sur la refondation de l'école et au même
moment bien la cour des comptes sort à
un rapport qui est finalement une
violente charge notamment contre le
recrutement de 60000 enseignants
supplémentaires
est ce qu'on peut dire que didier migaud
le président socialiste de la cour des
comptes ne fait pas de cadeau à françois
hollande
je pense qu'un rapport de la cour des
comptes s'est d'abord en rapport fait
par des gens dont la responsabilité est
d'être des comptables pas de définir une
politique mais c'est un travail de
comptable sur les dix dernières années
et il est extrêmement critique
je vous signale que ces dix dernières
années c'est pas nous qui étions en
situation de responsabilité et donc ceux
qui pensent trouver une critique contre
notre politique devrait être un peu plus
attentif au contenu de ce rapport
mais ce rapport et critiques notamment
sur le recrutement décidé par françois
hollande pendant la campagne
présidentielle de 60000 enseignants
supplémentaires
ce rapport d'abord n'est pas juste sur
le plan des créations ou des
disparitions d'emplois puisqu'il dit que
les effectifs en vue très stable il ya
une erreur nous la contestons c'est que
il prend en compte le montant des
pensions sur le volume financier global
mais ça ne fait pas des postes sa fédé
savez dépend saunier il ya bien eu 80
mille postes qui ont été supprimés par
l'ancienne majorité et les postes que
nous créons ils servent à quoi à deux
choses principalement d'abord redonner
une formation aux enseignants est-ce que
c'est pas un scandale dans ce pays que
le seul métier qu'on peut faire sans
avoir reçu de formation pédagogique ce
soit le mettez dans
saignant c'est comme ça que la droite
avait avait pratiqué et deuxièmement on
sait que tout se joue à l'école primaire
que des enfants qui sont dans les
milieux sociaux les plus défavorisés il
faut d'abord qu'ils aient accès à
l'école est ce que c'est normal
aujourd'hui de constater que la
scolarisation la scolarisation des moins
de 3 ans était de 34% en 2000 en 2012 on
est passé à 11 %
c'est peut-être pas le problème de la
cour des comptes c'est le problème d'une
politique éducative menée par un
gouvernement en exercice scolaire se
joue avec la scolarisation à trois ans
nous pensons nous pensons évidemment il
ya un débat il ya certains qui pensent
que non je pense que et tout le monde le
sait aujourd'hui c'est pour ça qu'on a
mis l'accent et sur l'école primaire et
éventuellement sur les scolaires et une
scolarisation plus jeunes parce que
c'est le moment notamment pour les
enfants qui n'ont pas un entourage
familial qui ont un entourage social
difficile d'avoir avec l'éducation cette
deuxième chance finalement et même très
jeune le rapport de la cour des comptes
prône aussi une révolution pour
augmenter les chances de réussite
scolaire le projet loi pour l'instant ne
va pas vraiment dans le sens d'une
révolution au niveau de la scolarité
c'est pas la révolution au niveau de la
scolarité mais l'ambition qui a été
donné par vincent peillon et qui reprend
qui repart pour partie reprises dans le
rapport de la cour des comptes sur la
nécessité de revisiter les conditions du
métier je crois que ça a été dit
annoncées pour la rentrée pour la
rentrée de septembre par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale on a l'impression
quand même que ça reste très difficile
de réformer l'éducation nationale et que
la gauche reste traumatisé par
l'expérience claude allègre dont je la
gauche est traumatisé par rien c'est
l'école qui est traumatisée par la
droite c'est ça la la la la la vraie
situation c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous
pouvez pas avoir une école qui
fonctionne quand vous supprimez des
postes 80 me pose enfin tous les
français ont vécu ça le remplacement
je n'ai pas cité enfin la réalité des
parents aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est
d'arriver à l'école un jour où il n'y a
pas de remplaçants eh bien c'est la
conséquence des suppressions de postes
c'est que la cour des comptes le veuille
ou pas ça c'est la réalité de la vie une
mauvaise ventilation nous fourrière il
nous faut bien des postes oui c'est
facile de dire ça la réalité c'est qu'on
a supprimé des postes de remplaçants
vous savez très bien ce qu'ils ont fait
ils ont supprimé la formation mais comme
et supprimer des postes pour pas que ça
se voie trop il
nuit directement les enseignants sans
aucune formation devant les élèves
ça a été ça l'adisq a été organisée dans
les dix dernières années mais in fine et
vous ne pensez pas que ce rapport va ça
vire finalement à vincent peillon dans
le fond ça va pousser à aller peut-être
un petit peu plus loin dans les réformes
dans l'éducation nationale
mais vous avez raison de dire le
ministre et du catcheur nationale n'a
jamais dit qu'il y avait un statu quo
après le vote de cet de loi il ya une
loi il ya des il y aura des réformes
toujours à faire dans ce domaine comme
dans d'autres
l'assemblée nationale a adopté ce matin
l'amendement au projet de loi de madame
fioraso sur l'enseignement supérieur qui
va permettre de donner des cours en
anglais dans certaines universités ce
que vous avez compris la polémique qui
avait autour de cette disposition
j'ai eu un peu de mal à comprendre parce
que el balah et regarde selon vous non
c'est pas un combat d'arrière-garde mais
c'est un combat qui à mon avis a été un
peu surjouée puisqu'en réalité ça existe
déjà
ça existait dans la loi dans la loi
toubon il s'agit simplement au fond de
permettre à l'université de faire ce qui
se fait ce déjà souvent dans les grandes
écoles avec cette idée d'accueillir ici
en france des étudiants qui sont pas
forcément francophone au départ mais ça
ne remet rien en cause je le dirai ce
après midi puisque je vais répondre à
une question sur à la place de geneviève
fioraso quête à l'assemblée nationale
les examens se feront en français et
franchement il n'y a aucune remise en
cause des fondements de la langue
française mois certains disent on ouvre
un pour cent des cours et puis c'est
donc la porte verte
après à des dérives vers d un
enseignement de plus en plus anglophone
oui on peut aussi veut fermer les yeux
fermer les frontières ne pas regarder ce
qui se passe dans le monde
j'ai pas sûr que c'est comme ça que la
france évoluera dans tous les cas c'est
pas notre vision
alain vidalis en tant que ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
vous devez gérer un calendrier
parlementaire surchargé
on va donc aller vers une session
extraordinaire cet été jusqu'à la fin du
mois de juillet jusqu'au 26 juillet
précisément d'accord et on reprend dès
le début du mois de septembre
je vous l'annoncé officiellement
reprendra non pas au tout début mai la
deuxième cette semaine à partir du 9
septembre donc reprise de la session
extraordinaire à partir de septembre
avec quels textes majeurs en septembre
aujourd'hui c'est pas définitivement
arbitré mais probablement ce que l'on
appelle la loi sur le logement dit duflo
de la loi sur l'économie sociale et
solidaire la loi sur le droit des femmes
voilà les principaux textes qui seront
examinés au moins à la rentrée une
inconnue subsiste c'est la tenue d'un
congrès ou non au mois de juillet autour
de la réforme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
est ce que vous allez organiser ce
congrès sur ce texte nous allons déjà
organisé nationale au sénat le vote
ensuite la question c'est est ce qu'il y
aura une majorité des trois cinquièmes
il en est où vous pensez c'est la
question est toujours la même il faut
qu'il y ait 30 une trentaine de voix
venant de l'opposition d'aujourd'hui qui
vote cette réforme qui est destiné à
garantir l'indépendance de la
magistrature
c'est assez triste de penser qu' il n'y
ait pas spontanément dans l'opposition
de droite aujourd'hui des gens pour
soutenir cette réforme si nous n'avons
pas la majorité
pour l'instant vous ne l'avez pas cette
majorité des 3 5e est pour l'instant le
discours qui est tenu
c'est aucune modification ne veut rien
voter de ce qui est proposé par par le
gouvernement je crois que ça n'est pas
raisonnable et que normalement ces
questions-là devrait faire consensus au
moins avoir une majorité qualifiée
j'espère toujours qu'on arrivera à
convaincre le président et publics la
ville lors sa conférence de presse jeudi
dernier à l'elysée la réforme autour du
droit de vote des étrangers a été
renvoyé après les municipales de 2014
est ce que c'est un échec de cette
majorité c'est pas du tout un échec
c'est de la main problème nous n'avions
pas la majorité des trois cinquièmes
pour le faire immédiatement le président
de la république a dit quelque chose de
laid je vous l'aurais plus cette
majorité des trois cinquièmes oui parce
que l'objection qui nous est faite par
les gens de droite pour dire qu' ils ne
veulent plus je dis ne veulent plus
parce qu'un certain nombre d'entre eux
avaient pris des engagements notamment
chez les centristes et notamment chez
les centristes mais ils nous disaient
vous allez modifier le résultat au fond
des élections municipales à venir donc
on les prend au mot on dit très bien le
président de la république a eu raison
il dit mais on le fera après les
municipales de telle manière que cet
argument conjoncturel n'existera plus et
que chacun devra se prononcer sur le
fond vous les avez consulté notamment
les centristes sur ce droit des
étrangers
mais c'est pas le de 2014 où les
addictions on les a consultés sur avant
la survie est non mais depuis vous avez
vous voyez bien qu'ils vont pas nous
dire aujourd'hui à ben on est prôné
contre avant on sera pour après
vis-à-vis d'elle un électorat on voit
bien que on essaye nous de se mettre
dans les conditions où cet engagement du
président de la république pourra être
tenue c'est je pense la meilleure chance
pour de pouvoir y parvenir et c'est
quand même ce qu'on demande au président
la république alain vidalis une dernière
question le conseil constitutionnel
avait validé la réforme du mode du
scrutin binominal sauf la répartition
des sièges des membres du conseil de
paris est ce qu'une solution a été
trouvée sur ce point et est ce qu'un
nouveau texte va arriver au parlement
il y aura forcément nouveau texte
puisque il faut qu'ils soient déposées
il ne l'est pas définitivement ce une
affaire assez compliquée qui va pas
bouleverser le monde
nous avions essayé de faire les choses
d'une manière raisonnable le conseil
nous a dit il faut aller plus loin que
ce que vous avez fait alors que la
critique c'était que déjà on nous
reprochait d'avoir bougé un peu les
choses
donc nous allons le faire et le ministre
l'intérieur déposera un projet de loi ou
alors une proposition de loi d'origine
parlementaire nous sommes obligés
d'aller assez vite dans quel délai dans
lequel il faut que ce soit fini avant
fin juillet pour que la règle du jeu
soit définitivement établi très bien
m'écouter
merci beaucoup alain vidalis d'être venu
sur notre plateau aujourd'hui en direct
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement vont démarrer d'ici une
minute ou deux je crois qu'on attend
encore dans le cabinet de départ le
président du sénat jean-pierre bel qui
va présider cette séance avec je les dis
des thèmes très variés qui vont être
abordés cet après midi on va commencer
par une question sur la gouvernance
économique européenne une question une
question du radical jean claude requier
etc thierry repentin le ministre chargé
des affaires européennes qui lui
répondra
parmi les autres sujets qui vont être à
bord de cet après midi et bien il y aura
la conférence sociale organisée en ce
moment par le gouvernement c'est une
question de la socialiste laurence
rossignol qui est également porte parole
du ps et michel sapin
le ministre du travail et du dialogue
social sera là pour lui répondre et puis
parmi les autres thèmes cet après midi
bien l'enseignement en anglais
l'université on vient d'en discuter avec
alain vidalis l'amendement la
disposition pardon du projet de loi de
geneviève fioraso a donc été adoptée ce
matin par l'assemblée nationale
une question sera posée par l'ump joëlle
garriaud-maylam et c'est alain vidalies
qui lui répondra
on aura d'ailleurs à partir de 16 heures
un débat sur cette question de l'anglais
des cours en anglais dans l'est dans les
universités sur ce plateau après la
séance c'est à dire aux alentours de 16
heures parmi les autres questions cet
après-midi et bien une question de
pierre bernard émond sur la situation en
syrie c'est laurent fabius le milieu des
affaires étrangères qui sera là pour lui
répondre
et puis d'autres questions économiques
sur sanofi et l'industrie pharmaceutique
arnaud montebourg répondra le crédit
d'impôt pour la compétitivité et
l'emploi et là c'est bernard cazeneuve
le ministre du budget qui répondra donc
vous le voyez des thèmes très très très
variés j'allais oublier la réforme de la
décentralisation qui évidemment un thème
qui intéresse très particulièrement ici
les sénateurs voilà le président du
sénat jean-pierre bel va rentrer dans
l'hémicycle il va s'installer pour
présider la séance
nous allons recevoir ces images dans
quelques instants et vous allez donc
pouvoir suivre ces questions d'actualité
en direct sur notre antenne je vous
rappelle que je vous retrouve ici en
direct à partir de 16 heures après la
séance avec nos invités le miso
l'éducation vincent peillon mais
également des sénateurs sur ces
diversions actualité pour en débattre
ensemble
à tout à l'heure le cher collègue il met
tout d'abord agréable de salut par dont
la présence dans notre tribune de
nombreux apprentis qui participe
aujourd'hui au sénat ou 13e rencontres
sénatoriales de l'apprentissage
en entretenant je leur souhaite je vous
souhaite à vous tous avouent tout le
succès un bon succès un grand succès
dans votre vie professionnelle je
rappelle l'ordre du jour les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement pour la
première question la parole est à
monsieur jean claude requier pour le
compte du rdr
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre chargé des affaires
européennes
monsieur le ministre la semaine dernière
à l'occasion de sa conférence de presse
le président de la république a parlé
d'europe et il a annoncé le lancement
d'une initiative européenne en quatre
points
le premier de ces quatre points je le
cite c'est d'instaurer avec les pays de
la zone euro un gouvernement économique
qui se réunira tous les mois
autour d'un président a nommé pour une
durée longue et qui seraient affectés à
cette seule tâche 1 les radicaux de
gauche et les membres du rdr ce qu a eu
l'honneur de compter dans l'europe
maurice faure signataire du traité de
rome soutiennent pleinement cette
initiative européenne du président de la
république nous l'approuvons d'autant
plus que nous appelons de nos voeux
depuis plusieurs années il ne fait
maintenant plus aucun doute que la
réponse à la crise économique et
financière que nous traversons ne
passera ni par un énième accord
financier provisoire ni par des plans
d'austérité nationaux mais bien par une
solidarité institutionnelle par un
encadrement communautaire des budgets
nationaux et par les politiques de
relance cohérente menée au niveau
européen
langer l'euro et c'est une réussite mais
nous sommes patients nous doter de la
politique économique commune qui en
était le corollaire indispensable nous
ont laissé se développer une politique
monétaire géré par la banque centrale
européenne et 27 politique budgétaire où
chacun des états a voulu profiter de la
stabilité de l'euro pour s'exonérer dans
les cécités de contrôler ses dépenses
cette dispersion du pouvoir économique
et donc le péché originel de la zone
euro elle est la principale faille dans
laquelle se sont engouffrés les
spéculateurs
oui il ne faut pas revenir au plus vite
à une véritable politique économique
commune
c'est la condition sinequanone pour ne
plus subir la pression des marchés
financiers et les conséquences de la
crise économique actuelle
c'est désormais un préalable pour aller
vers une union politique pour nous
membres du rdse
cela suppose de créer des mécanismes de
coordination reka bce et surtout de
remettre en cause son indépendance
catégorie total aussi faut-il comprendre
dans les propos du président du public
comme une volonté de contrebalancer le
pouvoir de la bce ou encore celui de la
commission nous espérons monsieur le
ministre
pouvez vous nous en dire davantage sur
cette initiative forte prise par le
président de la république quel rôle
institutionnel
la phrase souhaite coopérer exactement à
ce gouvernement économique européen
merci et comment allez vous convaincre
nos partenaires les plus réticents merci
la parole à monsieur thierry repentin
ministre chargé des affaires européennes
ce président monsieur le sénateur vous
avez raison lors de sa conférence de
presse la semaine dernière le président
a vu l'écart appelé de ses voeux
l'instauration au sein de la paix des
pays de la zone euro d'une gouvernance
économique
nous sommes en effet convaincus que
l'union économique et monétaire appel
en plus de la monnaie unique et la
banque centrale européenne un
gouvernement économique qui détermine et
conduisent une politique conforme aux
intérêts de la zone euro la gauche
française et tout particulièrement
effectivement les radicaux de gauche
le demande depuis la création de l'euro
on nous l'a d'ailleurs beaucoup annoncé
par le passé sans obtenir de réelles
avancées
or la crise a bien démontrer
l'insuffisance des structures existence
pour prendre en temps utile les
décisions qui s'imposent il est
aujourd'hui essentiel de remédier
rapidement à cette situation et ce que
nous souhaitons lorsque nous parlons de
gouvernants economics c'est d'abord une
autorité politique
identifiée pour l'europe une autorité
capable de fixer un cap de décider puis
d'agir
c'est aussi un gouvernement qui
permettent à l'europe de 5 à relais dans
une parole unique et c'est enfin
une responsabilité pour ce gouvernement
responsabilité devant les citoyens bien
évidemment mes responsabilités aussi
devant le parlement européen et les
parlements nationaux pour construire ce
gouvernement économique
nous devons réunir plus souvent le
sommet de la zone euro pour délibérer
sur la politique économique bien sûr qui
doit définir en appliques en impliquant
l'ensemble des institutions concernées y
compris la bce mais aussi délibérer sur
les questions de fiscalité et les
questions sociales qui pour nous sont
essentielles non devons aussi renforcer
leur groupe en le dotant d'une
présidence à temps plein et nous devons
mieux articuler ces institutions dans
une architecture cohérente et plus
solides ce gouvernement de la zone euro
doit être aussi doté d'une capacité
budgétaire
disposant de ressources distinctes en
plus du budget de l'union pour financer
des actions en faveur de la croissance
telle est la volonté du président de la
république telles sont nos objectifs
je veux d'ailleurs précisé que ces
avancées peuvent être engagées
immédiatement dans le cadre actuel des
traités de fonctionnement de l'union
européenne et les deux années qui
viennent permettront de prendre les
décisions nécessaires et urgents dans
ses perspectives
je sais compter sur votre soutien dans
ce dessein merci monsieur andré
reichardt pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à manuel
valls ministre de l'intérieur sur le
ministre il ya quelques jours à peine
dans le cadre des questions cribles sur
le terrorisme je vous interrogeait sur
les mesures à prendre pour tenter de
contrôler les flux internet et les
réseaux sociaux à strasbourg nous venons
d'être rattrapé par cette dangereuse
réalité les lycées sont en effet l'objet
d'une menace proférée depuis un
cybercafé de la cité le soir du 14 mai
dernier un internaute anonyme bien
entendu a publié un long message
intitulé tout s'arrête bientôt sur le
forum d'un site web dans lequel il
annonce son intention ni plus ni moins
que de commettre un massacre dans un
établissement scolaire à l'aide du semi
automatique de son oncle je cite si le
dispositif de sécurisation des
établissements scolaires concernés 7
heureusement mis en place rapidement je
voudrais à cet égard en remercier
notamment monsieur le préfet de
département ce procureur de la
république et les forces de police et de
gendarmerie concernées il est clair que
la menace ne doit pas être considérée
comme évacués et que plusieurs questions
se posent à cet égard en premier lieu
même s'il ne faut surtout pas
surenchérir dans de telles circonstances
il est indispensable de rassurer la
population alsacienne et tout
particulièrement les parents et les
élèves des établissements scolaires
concernés
quant à une sortie prochaine de cette
situation de crise à ce jour deux pistes
ont d'ores et déjà été exploitées par
les enquêteurs mais les personnes
interpellées ont été mises hors de cause
sans mettre en difficulté la nécessaire
confidentialité de l'enquète pouvez vous
nous donner monsieur le ministre
quelques informations à cet égard
ensuite plus de 500 policiers et
gendarmes sont mobilisés au quotidien
pour sécuriser les quelques 50
établissements de strasbourg menacée je
ne parle même pas du bas rhin se sont
bien entendu autant d'effectifs qui
manquent sur d'autres champs auxquels
ces forces sont normalement affectée
comment ces absences sont telles qu'on
pensait
enfin les cybercafés comme les cartes
téléphoniques prépayées constitue une
zone de totale liberté de non droit qui
permet dès lors tous les abus dont celui
ci n'a t-il pas lieu monsieur le
ministre de renforcer les outils de
veille électronique notamment dans ces
cybercafés voir d'instaurer une
obligation d'identification des usagers
de ces lieux et outils et pour être
encore plus efficace dans le contrôle
des flux internet
ne faut-il pas doter nos services de
police judiciaire et de renseignement
des moyens humains supplémentaires
particulièrement formés aguerris
collègues des nouveaux moyens de
communication tels sont monsieur le
ministre les questions comme inspire cet
événement survenu dans mon département
et auxquels je vous remercie de bien
vouloir et bien la parole est un
monsieur manuel valls ministre de
l'intérieur sur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur richard
nous reprenons en effet une discussion
que nous avons eue et à l'occasion de la
loi antiterroriste et encore vous venez
de l'évoquer jeudi dernier lors des
questions cribles sur le terrorisme
d'une manière générale nous devons être
mobilisés parce que la menace est là en
france en europe et dans le monde et les
derniers évènements de ces dernières
heures en font la démonstration et après
le président de la république et le
premier ministre je veux assurer la
solidarité du gouvernement à l'égard de
nos amis britanniques qui ont subi cette
attaque particulièrement terrible
horrifiante qui pose beaucoup de
questions sur la nature de la menace que
nous connaissons la nécessité d'une très
grande mobilisation
je veux à mon tour monsieur le sénateur
salué le travail l'engagement des forces
de l'ordre dans la sphère que vous
évoquez la menace posté sur un forum de
jeux a été repéré rapidement et un
dispositif adapté de sécurisation des
lycées a été mise en place immédiatement
il sera maintenu le temps qu'il faudra
ce sont 450 5 450 policiers et gendarmes
qui assurent aujourd'hui la protection
de ces établissements l'anc est ce pour
et toutes les pistes sont exploitées
l'encore l'engagement de la police
nationale est totale et la coordination
je crois de bonne qualité trois services
sont engagés la sûreté départementale
chargée de l'investigation de proximité
la police judiciaire bien sûr et enfin
l'office central chargé de la lutte
contre la délinquance liés aux nouvelles
technologies
la détection de la menace et la lutte
contre les rumeurs qui se répandent sur
internet passe enfin par un travail
accru avec des opérateurs et les réseaux
sociaux c'est par exemple ce que nous
avons entrepris avec twitter suis telle
recrudescence ces derniers mois de
propos antisémites et homophobes en
matière de surveillance d'internet nous
avons eu ce débat nous devons concilier
les impératifs de sécurité et les
grandes libertés constitutionnelles
c'est une tâche difficile mais les
services ne manquent pas d'outils
techniques ou de personnels spécialisés
qui savent identifier les cyber
délinquance ça sera le cas évidemment
pour la direction centrale du
renseignement intérieur et qui aura des
moyens supplémentaires notamment en
matière de recrutement
toutes les technologies doivent être
exploitées dans le cas de strasbourg
nous pouvons par exemple nous appuyer
sur les images de la vidéosurveillance
du cybercafé en tout cas monsieur le
sénateur les menaces de strasbourg
doivent être prises au sérieux leurs
auteurs doit être identifié et qu'il
s'agisse ou non d'un canular
il doit être sanctionné c'est ce que
nous faisons nous attelons évidemment à
cet objectif sans céder à la panique
mais avec beaucoup de détermination
merci la parole et un autre collègue
jean arthuis pour le groupe u10 us et la
question s'adresse à madame le garde des
sceaux madame la garde des sceaux
je souhaite attirer votre attention sur
une dérive qui met en péril l'exercice
par les départements de leur mission de
protection de l'enfance en effet nous
assistons insensiblement un transfert
des responsabilités de l'état vers les
conseils généraux à propos de l'accueil
des mineurs délinquants
les moyens de la protection judiciaire
de la jeunesse
en dépit de l'accroissement des crédits
ne permettent plus de faire face aux
besoins
dès lors
au nom de la graduation de la réponse
pénale les magistrats sont conduits à
confier de plus en plus fréquemment des
mineurs délinquants relevant normalement
de l' ordonnance de 1945 au service de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance c'est à dire
au département la situation en mayenne
met en évidence un dysfonctionnement
préoccupant le foyer d'hébergement de la
pjj a été fermé la direction
départementale a disparu au profit d'un
regroupement couvrant trois départements
il en résulte que les magistrats
confient les jeunes à la pjj en fonction
des places disponibles dans ses propres
foyers en mayenne près d'un tiers des
entrées en maison d'accueil d'urgence
entre janvier et avril 2013 concerne des
jeunes faisant l'objet de poursuites
judiciaires durant la même période et
corrélativement les agressions envers
les éducateurs se sont multipliées ainsi
que les saisies de couteau deux
pistolets à grenaille et autres coups de
poing américain c'est dire si le profil
de ces jeunes a changé dans les maisons
d'accueil d'urgence la présence des
mineurs délinquants mettent en danger
les autres enfants nous sommes ainsi
bien loin de la protection des jeunes
victimes de leur environnement familial
et social
les éducateurs eux mêmes sont en danger
dans une affaire récente un jeune confié
à l'aide sociale à l'enfance s'est livré
à une succession d'actes délictueux
conclu par le vol et l'incendié d'un
véhicule de service
interpellé par les gendarmes quelques
jours plus tard est présenté en
comparution immédiate au pénal
accompagnés d'un éducateur de la pjj
il fait l'objet d'une mesure de liberté
surveillée préjudicielle sans jugement
dans le cadre de l' ordonnance de 1945
le jeune reste donc sous l'assistance
éducative et la responsabilité du
conseil général motif le manque de
places dans les foyers d'hébergement de
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
j'aimerais connaître madame la ministre
les mesures que vous entendez prendre
pour mettre un terme à cette dérive
je voudrais vous convaincre que l'aide
sociale à l'enfance n'est pas la soupape
d'ajustement
de la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse merci monsieur prochaine fois
je vous interrogera sur le placement des
mineurs étrangers isolés merci madame
merci monsieur le sénateur un parent
dans nos christiane taubira en garde des
sceaux ni preuves justice monsieur le
président mesdames et sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
ministre
jean arthuis la l'aide sociale à
l'enfance n'est absolument pas la
soupape d'ajustement de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse
la situation que vous évoquez encore
qu'il faille vérifier les chiffres que
vous donnez pas ce qu'il ya des
divergences d'appréciation entre ce que
vous dites est ce que la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse recense il
n'empêche que c'est une situation qui
est juridiquement possible puisque
l'article 10 de l'ordonnancé de 1945
autorise effectivement le juge a placé
dans les hébergements de l'aide sociale
à l'enfance des jeunes qui ont été pris
en charge dans le cadre pénal
c'est l'article 10 de leur donnant de
1945 mais ce sont des situations
absolument exceptionnelle je les ai
vérifiés les cas que vous évoquez donc
que mérite d'être regardé de plus près
je vous propose un travail de
convergence avec la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse
mais je vais vous rappeler puisque vous
évoquez effectivement la fermeture de
direction départementale effectivement
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
entre 2008 et 2012 a perdu près de 600
emplois c'est à dire environ 8% de ses
effectifs
les crédits dévolus au service
associatif habilité qui vous le savez
prend en charge une part importante de
certains de nos publics ces crédits ont
baissé de 22%
c'est à dire de 67 millions d'euros le
président de la république a décidé de
faire de la jeunesse sa priorité le
premier ministre a procédé aux
arbitrages en ce sens de sorte que le
budget de la pjj augmenté de 2,4 pour
cent que nous avons recrutés dès cette
année 2013 205 personnel éducateurs et
psychologues
cent soixante dix huit éducateurs pour
une prise en charge sur l'ensemble du
territoire de ces jeunes dans les cinq
jours et que nous avons abondé la
dotation hors crédits courants des
associations de 10 millions d'euros
nous avons implanté la capacité
d'accueil dieu de la pjj
70 nouvelle famille d'accueil c'est à
dire une hausse de 20% en un an de 340 à
410 et nous avons légèrement augmenter
la dotation journalière de 30 à 36 euros
nous avons par ailleurs dans le semestre
2012 ouvert trois centres éducatifs
fermés nous en ouvrons 4 en 2013 et nous
cessons la fermeture des établissements
éducatifs
il y en a avec 18 dont la fermeture
était programmée pour 2012
nous avons maintenu ses établissements
en plus nous travaillons sur la
gouvernance de la protection de la
jeunesse nous le faisons
interministériel nous le faisons avec
les départements
je vous propose de travailler de plus de
façon plus plus coordonnée en tout cas
je la chancellerie vous est ouverte
vous y serez le bienvenu je vous informe
simplement que j'ai déjà reçu monsieur
claudy lebreton le président de
l'association des départements de france
nous continuerons à travailler en ce
sens merci la parole et corps
madame laurence rossignol pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'emploi de la formation professionnelle
et du dialogue social
monsieur le ministre hier s'est tenue à
matignon la réunion préparatoire à la
seconde conférence sociale qui elle-même
se réunira dans un mois
un mot d'abord sur la méthode car elle
est déterminante des résultats attendus
grâce à ce rendez vous réguliers et
honorer le gouvernement installe un
processus durable de réforme paraît
démocratie sociale parce qu'elle prend
acte de la diversité des points de vue
et travaille à les rapprocher sans les
heurter parce qu'elle rompt avec les
injonctions et les confrontations
brutales de la période précédente
parce qu'elle aboutit à des décisions
dans le respect et dans l' écoute
fusse-t-elle du sensuel
elle est la juste voie pour mobiliser
les partenaires sociaux dans la bataille
pour l'emploi tous d'ailleurs qu'ils
aient été ou non signataire d'un compte
des conclusions s'en félicite des
emplois d'avenir les contrats de
génération
l'accord interprofessionnel sont autant
de résultat déjà à l'actif de cette
méthode
il témoigne de la volonté du
gouvernement de réussir le redressement
du pays par la voie du dialogue social
et de la négociation l'emploi la
formation l'égalité professionnelle
hommes femmes les conditions de travail
l'équilibré des régimes de retraite sont
à l'agenda de ce deuxième rendez
tous ces sujets sont liés les salariés
sont méfiants dans le passé souvent le
mot réforme n'a été que le moyen de leur
infliger davantage de précarité
la formation est plus souvent vécu comme
un parking du chômage que comme une
deuxième chance
ils attendent des avancées sociales de
la sécurité professionnelle et une plus
grande efficacité
pouvez vous nous indiquer monsieur le
ministre quelles priorités et
calendriers ont été discutées et retenu
lors de la réunion d'hier
merci la parole à monsieur michel sapin
muse du travail de l'emploi de la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social
merci monsieur le président et merci
mais effectivement madame la sénatrice
pour cette question qui intéressera
surtout les bancs mesdames et messieurs
les sénatrices et sénateurs
il ya d'abord une méthode différente
vous l'avez souligné celle du dialogue
social n'est pas le dire le social
simplement dans les mots pas comme un
slogan pas comme une grand messe comme
on avait pu le connaître il n'y a pas si
longtemps une sorte de rendez-vous
éventuellement annuel dont on sortait au
ne plus en parler maintenant c'est une
méthode qui s'inscrit dans la durée
c'est la deuxième grande conférence qui
aura lieu en jeu en juin prochain
mais c'est tout au long de cette année
passée et tout au long de l'année à
venir
un des moments des rendez-vous des
méthodes d'été des sujets des
calendriers respectée par les uns et par
les autres est une satisfaction de
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux dont
vous pourriez aujourd'hui encore être
jaloux c'est ensuite c'est ensuite
madame la sénatrice des sujets est un
sujet qui est la préoccupation
fondamentale des français la prochaine
grande conférence sociale et tout le
monde nous l'a demandé hier au cours de
cette réunion de méthodes portera sur
l'emploi la lutte contre le chômage
le développement de l'emploi le
développement l'emploi à la fois par la
création d'emplois dans les entreprises
quel contexte créé dans quelles
conditions peuvent-elles travailler
mieux ou créer plus d'emplois l'emploi
parce que la formation professionnelle
vous avez fait allusion
c'est une condition fondamentale
aujourd'hui pour que ceux qui n'ont pas
d'emploi qui sont retrouvés
soit des jeunes n'ayant jamais eu
d'emploi mais n'ayant pas une formation
initiale suffisante ou que ce soit des
travailleurs licenciés à la recherche
d'un emploi et qui parle bien de
transition professionnelle par le biais
de l'appréciation d'une nouvelle
formation pourront trouver ainsi un
emploi et puis ce sont tous les autres
sujets parce que l'emploi s'est certes
la lutte contre le chômage mais l'emploi
c'est aussi la préoccupation de ceux qui
sont au travail
saleh il y a cinq millions de personnes
1 millions de plus au cours des
dernières années qui sont en situation
de mal emploi de pas d'emploi de pas
suffisamment de temps de travail mais il
ya 25 millions de françaises et de
français qui sont au travail et qui
veulent un meilleur travail de meilleure
qualité de meilleures conditions de
travail une meilleure santé au travail
une lutte contre la pénibilité au
travail pas simplement comme un élément
de la réforme des retraites
indispensable en termes de justice mais
de pénibilité chaque jour au travail
c'est aussi ça un des sujet qui sera
abordé au cours de cette grande
conférence et pillaient les aspects
européens puisque des initiatives sont
prises au niveau européen comme au
niveau franco allemand pour apporter des
solutions européennes louis l'europe
peut être aussi une solution apporter
des propositions pour lutter contre le
chômage des jeunes
je pense qu'il ya de quoi mesdames
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs de
quoi rassembler l'ensemble des énergies
merci la parole à monsieur joël labbé
pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt il
concerne la filière de production
porcine
la filière de production porcine est
comme hélas bien d'autres secteurs en
crise et avec des impacts lourd tant
sociaux économiques et environnementaux
et pas seulement en bretagne région qui
produit quand même 60 % de la production
porcine française
par ailleurs en dix ans le nombre
d'exploitations porcines a diminué de
23% passant de 7000 à 5699 pour être
précis dans ce contexte particulièrement
délicat
monsieur le prix monsieur le ministre
vous avez vous avez pris la situation à
bras le corps et on tient à vous saluer
a salué le fait que vous nous informer
et vous nous associer à vos décisions
autant que faire se peut vous avez
présenté annoncer et présenter un plan
d'avenir de la filière porcine sur ces
points donc vous annoncez vous l'a
retrouvé un niveau de production des 25
millions de têtes de 2010 aujourd'hui on
est tombé à 23 millions il y un petit
différentiel du fait que les unités sont
plus en plus forte en poids mais malgré
tout il ya nécessité à apprendre à
prendre les affaires en main consolider
le secteur abattage découpe et
transformation évidemment et en
travaillant sur la valeur sur la valeur
ajoutée mieux encadrer les relations
commerciales dans les filières agricoles
et agroalimentaires c'est une nécessité
et aussi mieux vendre avec la marque
française
il y à un véritable marché national à
reconquérir en termes de production la
nécessaire modernisation des soucis des
outils pardon à en facilitant
l'installation et la modernité la
modernisation des bâtiments
vous vous proposez d'alléger les
procédures administratives
cette question pose débat donc il s'agit
de s'aligner sur l'europe
effectivement mais n'oublions quand même
pas qu'il faudrait pas que ce soit 1,1 à
tous un assouplissement des normes
n'oublions pas que nous sommes sous le
coup de pénalité de mesures de risque de
pénalités européennes pour un non
respect de la directive nitrates et
enfin la matiz la méthanisation si elle
peut être une réponse elle ne doit pas
être un prétexte à une nouvelle vague de
concentration
il est nécessaire
je passe un mika ma question qui est en
3 par ici
merci s'il vous plaît la question oui
donc envisager vous monsieur le ministre
un retour au contrôle des structures
notament qui évite notamment celui de la
course à la concentration des
exploitations et qui est limite et
limite un certain nombre des limites de
d'exploitation encore via la seconde
question merci mettrait en évidence la
question de l'utilisation des terres
agricoles pour fournir des maïs à la
digestion des digesteurs il s'il s'agit
de réserver les terres agricoles à aux
productions agricoles merci de vos
réponses solides à la parole à monsieur
stéphane le foll ministre de
l'agriculture le président monsieur le
sénateur mais mesdames messieurs je vais
répondre à la question qui était vaste
et qui portait sur d'avoir une situation
extrêmement difficile de la filière
porcine française aujourd'hui qui
traverse les difficultés qui sont celles
de l'aube allemand d'élevage mais avec
une spécificité sur cette filière ça a
été évoqué qui a vu c'est lié à la
concurrence est liée au coût de
l'alimentation le niveau de sa
production en france b c on est passé en
2010 de 25 millions de têtes aujourd'hui
à moins de 23 millions 22 millions ce
qui a des conséquences sur l'outil de
transformation et des conséquences
sociales majeures ce matin il ya eu une
rencontre au ministère avec les salariés
de gad et les difficultés vous les
connaissez nous les connaissons en
particulier en bretagne
il faut donc avoir plusieurs stratégies
la première c'est celle qui consiste à
essayer dans cette filière très
difficile où le dialogue est pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'on devrait attendre de
mettre des gens autour de la table pour
pouvoir discuter d'une revalorisation du
prix en particulier sur la viande
porcine française l'idée d'ailleurs va
apporter d'ici début juillet a essayé de
fixer un cadre avec un cahier des
charges pour l'ensemble des viandes de
france pour que les consommateurs
puissent savoir que derrière cet
étiquetage il y à des conditions
sanitaires
il ya des conditions sociales de la
production qu'à une localisation de
cette production
il ya des conditions
alimentaires qui sont respectés et qui
permettent à partir de là de valoriser
ces viandes de france et puis la viande
porcine
c'est aussi le débat et la bretagne en
est depuis très longtemps un élément
conflictuelle d'ailleurs sur la zot qui
peut être en excédent et qui conduit à
ce qu'on appelle pour la bretagne et
algues vertes mais à la question de la
zot dans l'eau comment résoudre ce
problème
est-ce que c'est simplement une question
qui est posée par rapport aux nombres de
porcheries et haut niveau et au nombre
de ports qui sont produits en partie
mais pas totalement
il faut qu'on aborde cette question
maintenant avec une nouvelle démarche
est gelée proposé avec plusieurs étapes
la première c'est d'ouvrir la question
qui est posée sur la valorisation de cet
azote organiques alors qu'on sait que
même en bretagne alors qu'on est en
excès dans l'azoté organique
on achète et on épand de l'azoté minéral
donc on va engager une démarche qui va
consister à se poser une question toute
simple c'est que sur la question de la
zot on va résonner sur la zone totale si
j'ai de la dot organique en excédent je
n'ai pas besoin d azote minéral
ça c'est le premier changement majeur le
deuxième c'est valoriser aussi au
travers de la métallisation s'en aller
vers une croissance ou concentration
mais en ouvrant la possibilité à
plusieurs exploitations de pouvoir
s'engager dans cette valorisation de la
matière organique
voilà des réponses aux questions posées
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
christian favier pour le groupe sert ce
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de la réforme de l'état de
la décentralisation et de la fonction
publique dans une semaine
le sénat examinera un texte renforçant
les métropoles loin d'être une loi de
décentralisation
il concentre les pouvoirs locaux en
poursuivant l'effacement des communes et
des départements
entamée avec la réforme de 2010
l'entreprise ont c'est difficile à faire
passer diversion pas moins ont été
élaborés pour finalement aboutir à ces
représentations
sous la forme trois textes à la
cohérence incertaine le premier sur les
métropoles donne pleins pouvoirs à des
conférences territoriales pour imposer
aux départements et aux communes des
politiques locales venues d'ailleurs il
créer des métropoles dans plus de quinze
heures urbaine qui retire tout pouvoir à
près de 5000 communes réduit
l'intervention de plus de 40
départements et déstabilise l'action de
plus d'une douzaine de régions ce
bouleversement étant rappelé a touché
près de 30 millions de nos concitoyens
cette réforme on peut le dire et ben
l'ensemble de l'édifice républicain
fondé sur nos communes
notre attachement aux communes ne relève
pas de l'archaïsme la commune et pour
nous le creuset de notre système
démocratique à l'heure on sait où
l'éloignement des centres de décision
inquiète nos concitoyens et suscite
souvent leur colère la démocratie de
proximité
symbolisée par la commune et le
département constitue un atout et non
une charge comme l'affirment souvent
certains cercles libéraux devant ce
chamboulement généraliser la commission
des lois du sénat a supprimé on le sait
certaines mesures annoncées et réécrit
le texte sans remettre en cause son
orientation
madame la ministre le sénat dispose
dorénavant que d'une seule semaine pour
étudier ce nouveau texte et aucune
consultation n'est plus possible ne
permettant pas de faire vivre l'esprit
des états généraux que notre sénat a
organisé de solliciter l'avis des élus
des agents territoriaux et des
populations sur des sujets qui les
concernent directement
il n'est pas sérieux de travailler dans
ces conditions compte tenu de
l'importance des enjeux pour l'avenir de
nos territoires et de ce qu'ils vivent
nous vous demandons donc de repousser
l'examen de ce texte il faut le réécrire
briller introduire une nouvelle phase
réel de démocratisation de nos
collectivités territoriales leur
permettre de mieux répondre aux besoins
des populations en assurant leur
autonomie financière
comme le prévoit notre constitution et
enfin créer les conditions de leur
coopération volontaire pour développer
les services locaux en un mot faire
confiance à l'intelligence locale
et non la contrôler merci mon jeu n'est
de vos responsabilités madame la
ministre d'assurer un réel débat
démocratique dans un climat serein
respectueux de chacun
cette réforme doit formuler une nouvelle
étape montjean coloration démocratique
et sociale il refusait les dogmes
libéraux dont le seul objectif on le
sait la dame et la réduction des
services publics merci madame marylise
lebranchu ministre de la réforme de
l'état décentralisation et de la
formation de la fonction publique pardon
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur favier au moins l'ump applaudit
à la fin des dogmes libéraux c'est aussi
une nouvelle façon de dire les choses
je voulais juste vous dire d'abord sur
le texte sur le texte lui même monsieur
le sénateur c'est l'article 42 de la
constitution qui fait aujourd'hui que la
discussion porte sur le texte la
commission et non pas sur lui du
gouvernement donc le gouvernement à
déposer un texte nous avions appliqué
l'article 42 et débattre sur le texte
sorti de la punition
il n'en reste pas moins que le
gouvernement et moi-même avec un de
mariée escoffier avons bien l'intention
de défendre le texte du gouvernement à
travers un certain nombre d'amendements
du gouvernement sans aucun doute mais
aussi avec un excellent débat public sur
les amendements que les uns et les
autres avaient fait accepter par la
commission des lois mais vous insistez
sur deux points vous insister sur le
respect des communes je crois dans votre
question et vous insistez sur les
compétences imposé par les uns
collectivités territoriales aux autres
collectivités territoriales d'abord nous
avons tenu et nous aurions pu prendre un
autre engagement mais c'était celui du
président de la république avant même
qu'il ne souhaitait lui a gardé les
communes comme élément majeur et et
fondateur de la république
nous avons en particulier eu de longues
échange des longs échanges ici sur le
rôle du maire représentant de la
république mais aussi garante des
espaces de la conduite d'un certain
nombre de politiques et nous
nous tiendrons nous avons eu de longs
débats aussi sur la mutualisation des
services entre les communes et les
intercommunalités personne n'y reviendra
mais enfin monsieur le sénateur famille
nous avons choisi la confiance nous
aurions pu écrire durement les chefs de
file 1 à l'image de ce qui avait été
proposé en amont mais nous avons choisi
de demander aux élus de réfléchir entre
eux à la façon dont on peut se partager
des compétences à partir du moment où le
président de la république s'était
engagé à rétablir la clause de
compétence générale
maintenant il faudra que nous gérions
cette application de la clause de
compétence générale rendu à chacun et je
pense que ce que nous avons proposé en
terme de conférences de l'action
publique c'est justement la confiance
aux élus entre eux pour dire qui est à
même de faire tel ou tel aspect par
exemple concernant le développement
économique en termes de subsidiarité et
de ne pas imposer aux autres ses propres
choix
je pense que tout est assis sur la
confiance pour seul regret monsieur le
sénateur favier c'est que je n'ai pas
l'impression aujourd'hui que les élus se
fasse confiance entre eux merci la
parole à madame joëlle garriaud-maylam
pour le groupe ump
alors vous attendez c'est à moi ou pas
non s'il vous plaît si vous voulez bien
poser votre question
l'assemblée nationale vient d'adopter
toute à l'heure l'article 2 du projet de
loi visant réforme de l'université
article visons la multiplication des
cursus universitaire en anglais
cette mesure est présentée comme visant
à accroître l'attractivité des
universités françaises mais c'est là une
profonde erreur oui nous avons besoin de
renforcer l'apprentissage des langues et
pas seulement l'anglais monsieur le
ministre
au sein de notre enseignement et ce dès
le primaire
nous devons viser l'excellence par une
réforme profonde de nos universités et
nous avons le devoir d'y travailler
ensemble mais c'est d'abord par la
qualité de l'accueil des étudiants
étrangers que nous devons nous améliorer
avec bien sûr des cours intensifs de
mise à niveau linguistique pour les
étrangers notre objectif en tout cas ne
doit pas être de faire du chiffre mais
de former les meilleurs ambassadeurs de
notre diplomatie économique et d'
influence le filtre de la langue est à
cet égard un atout pas un obstacle car
c'est aussi une ouverture apprécié sur
un espace francophone en pleine
croissance économique et démographique
soixante pour cent des francophones ont
moins de 30 ans le français est la
seconde langue en progression mondiale
après le chinois et nous devrions
atteindre 700 millions de locuteurs à
l'horizon 2050
au delà du monde étudiant c'est un
signal très négatif de renoncement que
nous envoyons à l'international et que
nos partenaires francophones ne nous
pardonneront peut-être pas mes chers
collègues
et comment ne pas nous juger
schizophrène quand nous encourageons
l'enseignement du français l'étranger
tout en nous ex
néron de nos responsabilités
linguistique sur notre sol
pourquoi chine océan programme de cent
mille formateur pour l'afrique
si nous abandonnons notre langue dans
l'enseignement supérieur
que dire à ces jeunes qui font l'effort
d'apprendre le français dans nos lycées
dans nos instituts et nos alliances à
l'étranger dans l'espoir de l'étudier
dans notre pays il ne s'agit évidemment
pas d'interdire tout court aux langues
étrangères à l'université
il s'y pratique des gens mais de refuser
l'inscription dans la loi d'une mesure
aussi absurde aussi négative les
hispanophones les use of honey la chine
redoublent d'efforts en faveur de
chocolat vous permet-il inde la chine a
créé en afrique une chaîne de télévision
merci 16 est-ce que nous allons
capituler monsieur le ministre si la
parole à monsieur alain vidalies strapi
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice vous demande d'abord d'excusés
geneviève fioraso qu'est justement dans
le débat sur la réforme de
l'enseignement supérieur et je vais vous
donner les éléments de réponses qu'elle
a préparé mais je voudrais y ajouter
parce que la nature de votre question me
oblige de rappeler au préalable que nous
n'avons pas décidé de modifier la
constitution et que la langue de la
république restera bien le français
j'ajoute j'ajoute que l'article
l'article 2 du projet de loi a
naturellement a naturellement un engagé
un débat parfois dans des conditions
assez outrancière et chacun s'y
reconnaîtra lorsqu'on évoque l'abandon
de notre langue
après l'adoption de ce texte je rappelle
que le principe suivant lequel le
français la langue de l'enseignement des
examens et des concours reste et restera
la règle le projet de loi prolongée
précise des dispositions qui existent
déjà dans la loi puisque dans le droit
positif
if avant même la modification qui vous
est proposé il est prévu une exception
en faveur des établissements dispensant
un enseignement à caractère
international c'est le résultat de la
loi toubon que votre majorité avaient
soutenu l'article 2 est donc très loin
d'introduire l'anglais comme langue de
droit commun au sein du service public
il ne prévoit pas que il ne prévoit pas
que des formations existantes
basculeront en anglais il n'ouvre aucun
droit à suivre un enseignement ou à
passer un examen dans une autre langue
que le français
trois raisons ont conduit le
gouvernement à retenir cette rédaction
pragmatique et encadré de l'article 2
d'abord une demande qui émane des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
elle figurait dans la synthèse du comité
dé pilotage des assises de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche et à d'ailleurs été reprise
par jean yves le déaut dans son rapport
sur la traduction législative des
assises ce sont les acteurs de
l'enseignement eux mêmes ceux qui ont
directement en charge recrutement et la
formation des étudiants étrangers qui
estiment cette mesure nécessaire la
deuxième raison tient à l'attractivité
de notre enseignement supérieur
la qualité de nos universités de nos
écoles constituent le premier critère
d'attractivité mais à qualité égale
certains étudiants issus de pays
émergents font de la langue de
l'enseignement un critère de sélection
est devant ce fait les établissements
doit pouvoir eux-mêmes déployer la
stratégie de leur choix la troisième
raison c'est la nécessité de préciser et
d'encadrer un mouvement qui existe déjà
l'offre de formation aujourd'hui
comprend plus de 700 par monsieur mills
us 10 en interne permis dispensés dans
une langue étrangère
aujourd'hui il s'agit de promouvoir
l'attractivité de la france et je pense
que le débat qui a lieu ce matin à
l'assemblée nationale et qui aura lieu
au sénat montrera que c'est plutôt la
voie du progrès et qu'il n'y a rien
changé
pour notre leur merci monsieur jean
jacques mirassou pour le groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur arnaud montebourg ministre du
redressement productif
il y a maintenant presque un an la
direction de sanofi annoncé dans le
cadre d'une restructuration de sa r&d la
perspective de fermeture de la plate
forme de recherche toulouse à l'horizon
2015 la mobilisation tout le monde le
sait des salariés a été forte immédiate
un essai du reste depuis jamais démenti
en prenant au fil des semaines l allure
d'un bras de fer avec une direction qui
n'était pas prédestiné à accepter un
dialogue social dès le départ avec
l'appui des élus concernés vous êtes
monsieur le ministre
saisi de ce dossier en refusant la
fatalité la disparition d'un site de
recherche et ses 600 nos emplois qui a
fait ses preuves en découvrant des
molécules de médicaments
maintenant mondialement connu faut-il au
passage rappelé que le laboratoire
sanofi enregistre des bénéfices
confortables le mot est faible et qu'il
occupe bon an mal an les premières
places au sein du classement du cac 40
par la suite vous avez confié monsieur
le ministre à deux personnalités
incontestables une émission destinée à
retracer l'avenir du site toulousain
le rapport de cette émission a été
rendue publique vendredi dernier en
préfecture de haute garonne au cours
d'une table ronde qui réunissait les
représentants des syndicats la direction
de sanofi et les élus haut garonnais il
ressort de cette rencontre et
conformément aux conclusions du rapport
que le site toulousain est considéré
comme viable
moyennant une réorganisation qui passe
par une nouvelle architecture de la
recherche et qui permettait donc
d'identifier et de valider de nouveaux
médicaments
le rapport par ailleurs et ce n'est pas
la moindre des choses reconnaît la
compétence incontestable du personnel
toulousain enfin vous n'avez pas ménager
vos efforts monsieur le ministre
pour que ce même rapport soit considérée
par le plus grand nombre comme un socle
permettant de réenclencher enfin le
dialogue entre les salariés et la
direction
ceci est du reste à notre sens le
passage obligé pour consolider j'ai
failli dire construire un nouvel avenir
pour sanofi toulouse qui est mérite par
ailleurs d'être fortement impliqué dans
la dynamique du futur os pour la
question c'est ma question monsieur le
ministre est très simple comment
allez-vous continuer à agir pour
accompagner et conforter cet avenir cet
espoir
merci monsieur arnaud montebourg
ministre du redressement productif
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs jeu monsieur le
sénateur jean jacques mirassou vous avez
rappelé les explications franches que le
gouvernement comme les élus d'ailleurs
du territoire toulousain et d'ailleurs
ont eu avec sanofi premières
capitalisations au cac 40
nous avons dans la première phase de
cette discussion qui fut difficile et
âpre chacun le reconnaît obtenu car nous
sommes partis de loin
d'abord un certain nombre de concessions
de la part de sanofi
avant même que le problème de toulouse
n'était en particulier posé et faisant
l'objet d'un début de solution
d'abord la proposition de sanofi était
de supprimer 2000 postes et ils ont
réduit accepté après discussion avec le
gouvernement à 917 suppression ils ont
accepté également zéro licenciement ce
sont des suppressions de postes mais ce
ne sont pas des licenciements
troisièmement ils ont déclaré vouloir
maintenir les centres de décisions
sanofi sur le territoire national et les
26 sites de production en france
enfin ils se sont engagés à maintenir le
haut niveau de recherche développement
et des dépenses en la matière à un
milliard huit c'est à dire 40 % de la
recherche développement total de sanofi
sur le territoire français ça c'est être
sans la considération des dégâts fait
sur le territoire toulousain
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
demandé à monsieur jean pierre st touil
un expert
incontesté qui était adjoint d'ailleurs
du professeur à l'université paul
sabatier mathieu amalric qui ont entendu
toutes les parties dès le mois de
février et ont rendu leur rapport la
semaine dernière en votre présence en
présence des élus et en ma présence
ainsi que les partenaires sociaux
quelles sont les propositions du rapport
sain touil 1
nous souhaitons pendant cinq ans que
sanofi maintiennent un centre
d'innovation ouvert à toulouse
permettant l'emploi sous la bannière
sanofi de 250 employés actuels
chercheurs le point numéro deux c'est
une proposition du rapporteur
nous allons créer dit il des structures
communes entre sanofi et le monde
académique l'université de toulouse de
manière à créer les conditions du
transfert de technologie et de recherche
troisièmement sanofi s'engage à financer
la création de start up et d'entreprises
innovantes pour quelques une petite
centaine d'emplois enfin ils
maintiennent les fonctions support et
enfin dernièrement l'ensemble des
propositions permet de considérer qu'il
y à 450 emplois maintenus à toulouse
sous ses diverses formes dont le
principal pour cinq ans de ce point de
vue là c'est un compromis
c'est un compromis où personne ne perd
personne ne gagne ce qu'il souhaitait
gagner les uns voulaient faire tout
disparaître les autres voulaient le
statu quo intégral je crois que le
moment et je suis le seul e jo lac ce
dialogue social serait embraye et arrive
à un compromis puisque la direction de
sanofi a accepté les conclusions du
rapport je souhaite que les partenaires
sociaux les syndicats à leur tour vienne
à la table négocié les modalités de mise
en oeuvre du rapport
cécile chance pour toulouse merci la
parole à monsieur francis delattre pour
le groupe ump monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur glisse du
budget
dans un grand fracas médiatique monsieur
gallois nous propose ici même le 7
novembre dernier de créer un choc de
compétitivité en transférant 30
milliards des charges sociales des
entreprises via la fiscalité à parité à
50% aussi sur les économies du secteur
public
la loi de finances 2013 est déjà
beaucoup plus modeste elle ramené le
chiffre 20 milliards et après bien des
discussions nous avions compris que pour
l'année 2013
l'objectif était de 10 milliards
d'allègements réellement inscrits dans
les comptes des administrations
publiques
le rapport gallois en ces préconisations
semblait indiquer une prise de
conscience du gouvernement des effets
négatifs de sa politique économique
fondée dans les six premiers mois
essentiellement sur des prélèvements et
pas formelle sur la stigmatisation des
entrepreneurs près de six mois après les
annonces où en sommes-nous mes chers
collègues pour 2013 le préfinancement
est effectué assez curieusement par la
banque publique d'investissement se
chiffre aujourd'hui ce gif à 660
millions
et d'après le patron le directeur
général de cette institution confirmée
par le directeur du budget le chiffre de
2 milliards sera un maximum pendant
l'année 2013 vous comprendrez donc entre
10 milliards et 2 milliards
il y a quand même là un vrai problème
avec la boîte à outils qui se révèlent
parfois être une véritable boîte à
malice le crédit d'impôt compétitivité
reste aujourd'hui monsieur mise à grands
flots budgétaires notamment sur les
économie affectée puisque la moitié de
son financement c'est sur les économies
mais l'expérimentation en cours on peut
mesurer des gens la pac réel du
dispositif 6
quels sont les salariés concernés
l'absence de dégressivité de la limite
de 2 5% explique conduit en réalité un
blocage des salaires moyens à 2 canal
smic
l'entreprise obtient 1700 euros
dégrèvement à 2,51 aucun smic malgré
l'instruction fiscale du 40 qu'une page
les entreprises ont des difficultés à
calculer entre les primes le 13
moi les abattement pour frais
professionnels a calculé un véritable
smic annuel alors deuxième à
l'interrogation quelles sont les
entreprises qui bénéficient puisque
c'était l'industrie qui était visé
essentiellement en tête des
bénéficiaires la grande distribution 3
milliards d'euros les grandes
entreprises de travaux publics 2
milliards d'euros
on peut dire qu'elles sont peu
délocalisables par rapport aux
entreprises en difficulté monsieur le
ministre qui s'en occupe
psa chercherait qu'il faut arriver à la
question ils ont dépassé votre temps
large 100 millions d'euros à comparer
avec 15 c'est aussi dangereux entre 110
et 180 messieurs le ministre l'objectif
de la réindustrialisation pas cette
mesure n'est pas à temps j'aurais savoir
quelles mesures il compte prendre pour y
remédier très bien la parole à monsieur
bernard cazeau neuf ministres chargés du
budget sur le sénateur merci pour votre
question qui est l'occasion de faire un
point sur les conditions de mise en
oeuvre du crédit d'impôt compétitivité
emploi et de l'ensemble des mesures qui
sont prises pour favoriser le retour à
la compétitivité de notre secteur
productif je voudrais vous apporter une
réponse la plus précise possible
concernant les dispositifs mis en oeuvre
depuis l'instruction de février 2002 ne
2013 à laquelle vous faites référence
pour faire en sorte que cette mesure
soit rapidement préempté par les
entreprises d'abord cette mesure est
simple elle s'inspire de mesures
antérieures qui avaient été prises par
d'autres gouvernements que vous
souteniez à l'époque elle est un ex
temps une extension du crédit d'impôt
elle permet aux entreprises en ligne de
bénéficier immédiatement de la mesure
elles pourront comptabiliser cette
mesure dès 2013 pour améliorer leurs
comptes d'exploitation elles pourront le
faire aussi pour faire baisser dès 2013
leurs prix pour celles d'entre elles qui
sont soumis à la concurrence
internationale
elles pourront aussi pour un certain
nombre d'entre elles qui sont en
difficulté de trésorerie bénéficié de
l'effet du crédit d'impôt non seulement
en comptabilité mais immédiatement
comment peuvent elles faire nous avons
mis en place un dispositif auprès de la
bpi qui permet à ces entreprises en
ligne de pouvoir bénéficier
dès 2013 de ce crédit d'impôt cela
représente à peu près 500 à 600 millions
d'euros de mobiliser mais nous avons
souhaité aller au delà et pierre
moscovici a signé une convention avec la
fédération française des banques avec le
secteur de l'entreprise avec notre
ministère pour que les banques
elles-mêmes puisse ouvrir la possibilité
sur les territoires d'accès à ce crédit
d'impôt pour les entreprises de leur
ressort
cela est rendu possible par un mécanisme
de garanties offertes par la bpi qui va
monter permettre la montée en puissance
de la mesure au cours de l'année 2013
enfin vous interroger et d'ailleurs vous
est légitime à le faire la question est
intéressante elle est légitime pour les
entreprises certaines d'entre elles nous
interroge sur la portée de cette mesure
par rapport à d'autres dispositifs
d'allégements de charges
je veux simplement vous rappelez sans
esprit de polémique que le crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi va
représenter un allègement de charges sur
les entreprises de 20 milliards
la fameuse tva sociale eux voté et
différée voulue par le précédent
gouvernement représente représenter un
allègement social de 12 milliards et
représenter un coût pour l'état beaucoup
plus important je veux vous rassurer
monsieur le sénateur nous présenterons
l'effet de cette mesure tout au long des
débats budgétaires à venir et vous
rendrez compte que vos présents
prévention d'aujourd'hui était infondée
je suis convaincu que vous soutiendrez
avec ardeur cette mesure dans ses effets
et pour les entreprises de notre pays
merci la parole à monsieur serge larcher
pour le groupe socialiste apparentés
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur victorin lurel ministère
outre-mer la problématique de la vie
chère constitue un sujet de débat et de
mobilisation sociale lancinant dans nos
d'outre-mer il ne s'agit pas que de
ressenti mais bien d'une égalité
statistique
ainsi l'insee estime que le niveau
général des prix dans les départements
outre-mer est supérieur de 6 à 13
poussant au niveau des prix dans
l'hexagone cet écart atteignait près de
même de 40 % pour les produits
alimentaires
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement a
fait de la vie chère outre-mer une de
ses priorités comme la liste et le vote
moins de six mois après sa prise de
fonction de la loi relative à la
régulation économique outre-mer ce texte
dont j'ai l'honneur d'être à porter le
sénat commence à produire des résultats
les négociations engagées avec la grande
distribution permet ainsi la baisse de
plus de 10% des prix des produits du
bouclier qualité prix ainsi que les
soeurs de certains produits issus la
production locale
au delà des prix des produits
alimentaires
le prix des carburant pèse lourd demande
le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
ultramarins il a d'ailleurs été le
déclencheur de la grave crise sociale
qui a touché nos outre-mer un début de
l'année 2009
il s'agit pourtant d'un prix réglementé
le précédent gouvernement a publié en
novembre 2010 un d'extrait produisant à
compenser sur la base d'un savant calcul
le manque à gagner des compagnies
pétrolières le local filiale de total en
application ce décret l'état a dû faire
assez compagnie un chèque de 144
millions d'euros pour la période 2009
2012 lors des débats c'est à dire la loi
relative à la régulation économique
outre-mer vous vous êtes vous étiez
engagé monsieur minus a modifié ce
décret où en est on aujourd'hui six mois
après l'avoir votée
merci merci de ces victorin lurel
ministre d outre-mer mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur serge larcher
je comprends votre impatience et je sais
qu'elle est partagée par nombre
de nos compatriotes des des autres mais
je vis la chose moi même parce que c'est
un sujet très technique mais avant de
vous répondre sur le fond
relativisons on peut les choses nous
avons pris ici même une loi portant
régulation économique des outre-mer six
mois après la plupart des décrets des
projets de décret sont prêts je vous
demande de comparer ce qui a été fait
lorsque l'inspection générale des
finances a publié son rapport portant
précisément sur les carburants c'était
en mars 2009 on a publié le décret que
nous voulons révisé et qui fait l'objet
de votre question on y amis fêter un
mois publié en décembre 2010 alors je
peux vous assurer aujourd'hui et devant
ici le sénat il y a quelques jours le
premier ministre a arbitré les grandes
orientations de la de la réforme alors
on procède aujourd'hui à quelques
vérifications techniques pour des
précisions de rédaction si j'ose dire
avant de transmettre le projet de décret
aux collectivités qui doivent être
nécessairement consulter et avant
d'avoir l'avis de l'autorité de la
concurrence est bien entendu le conseil
d'état sur le fond les grandes réformes
les grandes orientations qui ont été
retenus c'est d'abord tout faire en
transparence avoir une loyauté dans la
formation des prix
pour que chaque opérateur s'y retrouve
les grandes orientations c'est d'abord
là les prix d'importation des
hydrocarbures qui seront vendus plus
transparentes en donnant un rôle central
au prix de marché c'est-à-dire aux
cotations public
ensuite les comptes annuels des
entreprises réguler seront désormais
contrôlés chaque année ce qui n'était
pas le cas aujourd'hui afin de détecter
la constitution de revenus supérieurs
aux prévisions et d'apporter les
corrections nécessaires
je vous rappel c'est sur des budgets
prévisionnels que ce fonds
les fixations de prix ce n'est jamais
contrôlés enfin on va distinguer c'est
important une marche spécifiques
accordés aux gérants de stations
services afin de bien identifier ce qui
lui revient en propre et ce qui revient
au propriétaire de la station nous
voulons connaître les marges nettes et
non plus comme aujourd'hui dans les
outre-mers des marges brutes
je rappelle que les émeutes on peut dire
ça comme ça on commençait en guyane pour
un carburant à 1euro 77
le carbon le plus cher au monde et
christiane taubira peut en témoigner
parce qu'elle a vécu
c'est un événement en face d'autres
mesures importantes seront prises comme
la régulation séparer des stocks
stratégiques et un retour un taux de
rémunération unique de la raffinerie des
antilles et de la srp mexique est miné
monsieur j'ai demandé aux préfets
d'engager des concertations peau prendre
les nouveaux arrêtés deux méthodes là le
décret sera prêt avant la fin de l'été
merci la parole à monsieur pierre
bernard émond pour la réunion
administrative des sénateurs de figurant
sur aucun groupe
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères monsieur le ministre
le dramatique conflits qui déchirent la
syrie qui a déjà fait tant de morts et
créé tant de souffrance semble avoir
évolué récemment dans trois dimensions
au plan intérieur les observateurs
parlent de rééquilibrage des forces en
faveur du pouvoir en place ainsi que
d'un renforcement des extrémistes au
sein des forces de libération au plan
régional
jamais les répercussions du conflit
syrien sur les pays du proche et
moyen-orient n'ont été aussi dangereuse
pour leur intégrité et pour la stabilité
de la région
au niveau international sans parler de
nouvelle guerre froide
force est de constater que la russie et
la chine d'un côté les états unis et
leurs alliés de l'autre ont des analyses
et des intérêts très divergents
à la veille d'une tentative de réunion
d'une conférence internationale né de la
conviction
que ce conflit ne pourra pas se régler
par les armes
monsieur le ministre face à cette
situation en pleine évolution
quelle est aujourd'hui l'analyse de la
france juge t'elle opportun de prendre
de nouvelles initiatives
merci la parole à monsieur laurent
fabius ministre des affaires étrangères
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le ministre
merci de votre question qui pose je
crois très bien les données de ce
redoutable problème j'étais jusqu'à tard
dans la nuit
en jordanie où nous discutions d'une
part avec les dix autres pays qui sont
au soutient la coalition et avec la
coalition elle même de ce que nous
envisageons de faire
premier principe auquel nous ne
dérogeons pas
nous soutenons la coalition nationale
syrienne composée d'hommes et de femmes
qui résistent à l'offensive de bachar el
assad et qui sont animés par des
principes qui peuvent nous rassemble et
nous les soutenons depuis très longtemps
nous continuer à la soutenir
ce qui pose aussi le problème je n'ai
pas le temps d'étudier jusqu'au bout de
l'éventuelle levée de l'embargo sur les
armes
il ya eu depuis quelques semaines une
évolution sur le terrain vous avez
raison de souligner dans la mesure où un
certain nombre d'extrémistes du côté des
résistants ont pris des positions de
plus en plus forte mais pour nous il ne
doit pas y avoir de confusion et c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles nous
avons demandé aux nations unies
d'inscrire alnot sera sur la liste des
organisations terroristes de la même
façon au cours des dernières semaines le
hezbollah la branche armée du hezbollah
c'est à dire les iraniens le
démembrement des iraniens et dont plus
en plus présents et notamment dans la
tacc d'al qousseir c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai annoncé hier que la france
avait décidé dans le cadre européen de
proposer avec d'autres collègues
européens que la branche armée du
hezbollah soit inscrite parmi les
organisations terroristes
deuxièmement il n'y a de solution
politique vous avez eu raison de le
souligner nous avons depuis très
longtemps demandé qu'il y ait une
conférence dite de genève 2 celle-ci
possiblement nous le souhaitons va avoir
lieu mais il ya des conditions et m pour
qu'elle puisse être un succès
ce sont des conditions qui tiennent aux
participants c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons pris position pour
que l'iran qui ne souhaitent pas une
solution dans cette affaire soit écarté
de cette conférence et d'autre part se
pose évidemment la question de l'objet
de la conférence il faut s'en tenir à ce
qui était un article de genève un que
j'ai cosigné avec d'autres partenaires
l'année dernière il faut que l'objet de
la conférence consiste à installer à
gouvernement de transition qui soit doté
des pleins pouvoirs
y compris sur les forces de sécurité ce
qui est du même coup fait tomber si l'on
peut dire
la question de monsieur bachar el-assad
et puis se pose un problème des armes
chimiques ce qu'elle nous insistons il y
à des enquêtes y compris par la france
qui sont en cours dans le communiqué que
nous avons fait hier nous avons dit que
s'il était établi qu' il y a eu
utilisation des armes chimiques
la réponse serait sévère ce qui signifie
des choses très précises en termes de
droit international et en termes de
frappe
voilà monsieur le sénateur ce que je
peux vous dire c'est évidemment un drame
épouvantable qui a des conséquences
humaines terrible et les conséquences
sur l'ensemble de la région
la france essaye d'apporter sa pierre à
la solution en étant à la fois fidèle à
ses principes et pragmatique compte tenu
des évolutions sur le terrain merci mes
chers collègues nous en avons fini avec
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h15 pour la suite
du projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation pour la refondation de
l'école de la récup pour cette séance
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement que vous avez pu suivre en
direct sur notre antenne
on se retrouve tout de suite pour
refaire ensemble la séance